avec ses remparts sa collégiale et satu
fendu semur-en-auxois peut
s'enorgueillir d'un patrimoine
exceptionnel mais c'est un bâtiment
flambant neuf un gymnase économes en
énergie qui fait aujourd'hui la fierté
du maire philippe billet nos nous avons
tenu à boucler ce dossier donc sur le
plan du financement et sur le plan de la
réalisation technique avec succès et
aujourd'hui c'est ce que cette réussite
là qui nous dit qu qui me permet de dire
que on a réussi ça donc on doit réussir
d'autres choses fin prêt pour un second
mandat
philippe cuillé noces et déjà donner un
nouvel objectif la réhabilitation du
théâtre aujourd'hui fermée pour des
raisons de sécurité le maire sortant
fait de la réouverture du lieu rien
moins que le symbole du développement de
la ville
l'objectif pour 2020 et 5000 habitants
il faut qu'on ait plus d'habitants il
faut qu'on ait plus d'emplois et il faut
qu'on ait une ville qui soit vivante et
pour cela le rayonnement culturel de la
ville qui a toujours été très fort doit
s'appuyer sur ce théâtre qui est magique
la réouverture du théâtre figure aussi
sur le programme de michel neugnot
l'ancien maire ps il repart en campagne
clairement pour rattraper le temps perdu
c'est même le nom qu'il a donné à sa
liste ce qui s'est produit pendant six
ans onana souffert on en a souffert
et beaucoup de jeunes ruano souffert et
nous l'ont dit et donc quand vous voyez
des femmes et des hommes en souffrance
sur tel ou tel domaine
eh bien vous ne pouvez rester insensible
à la tête de la municipalité de 1997 à
michel neugnot espère bien récupérer son
fauteuil perdu en grande partie à cause
de son soutien à un projet de décharge
qui avait empoisonné la campagne j'ai
toujours est à contre-courant
comme tout le monde l'a gagné la
dernière fois j'étais un des seuls à
perdre donc je me dis que ça pu
continuer et dans le duel qui se prépare
entre l'ancien et l'actuel maire de
semur catherine sadon espère bien faire
autre chose que compter les points je
pense qu'il faut une autre manière de
gérer cette ville et dans la sérénité
dans l'apaisement et je pense par
ailleurs qu'une touche de féminité peut
aussi apporter une autre une autre façon
de voir les choses
ce que catherine sadon voix c'est ce qui
n'a pas changé comme c était qui
consolide les remparts du provisoire qui
dure c'est un vrai symbole à à plusieurs
titres d'une part 12 ans ça veut dire
plus qu'un mandat municipal ses deux
mandats
c'est par ailleurs une image de la ville
qui se dégradent pour laquelle
malheureusement on n'a pas commencé de
résoudre le problème avec les trois
mêmes acteurs semur-en-auxois va rejouer
la même pièce qu'en 2008
même le décor n'a pas changé depuis six
ans